local pastor facing sexual assault
charges this morning police arrested
this man here 45-year-old bobby smith in
north las vegas last week his arrest
report details incidents dating back
years including allegations that the
church new beginnings ministries knew
what was happening
this morning we're hearing from a father
who says 10 years ago his daughter was
sexually assaulted by smith
the father didn't want to be identified
but he said he worked side by side with
smith and went to confront him about the
allegations he says he was immediately
thrown out of the church altogether
i was in leadership in the church i was
a deacon of that church my daughter told
me this her side of the story and my
wife told me side of story i cried like
a baby and then it turned into rage as a
father
you feel like i let her down
i took her to church
i went there first as a man and then i
came home and told my family this is
where we going just because we need god
and they they took advantage of us they
took advantage of our trust
smith has been charged with three counts
of sexual assault one count of child
abuse he's currently out on bail he's
due back in court on november 7. as
always if you or someone you know is a
victim of assault there are resources
available and that includes a national
sexual assault hotline and hear locally
signs of hope the rape crisis hotline
both of those numbers are on your screen
now and we also have them posted to
8newsnow.com